historically big Tech has been the go-to
destination for some of the smartest
software Engineers data scientists and
product managers in the world with the
bleeding edge of projects and the topof
the line salaries it's no wonder why
Superstars are drawn to these companies
or at least they used to be it turns out
that more and more Superstars don't want
to join big tech companies in fact just
recently Facebook was having a bit of a
hiring crisis when only half of their
top tiar job offers were being accepted
a large reason for this is that many of
these applicants weren't actually
looking to work at Facebook or any other
big tech company at all rather they
simply applied and went through the
interview process in order to get a
strong anchor from which they can
negotiate with the companies that they
actually want to join it's not much
different with the people who did end up
joining these companies either many of
them only see these companies as a means
to an end a way to gain experience build
a strong resume and climb the corporate
ladder before starting their own company
or joining a project that they're
actually passionate about this isn't a
new trend either for decades the startup
scene has been dominated by ex big Tech
employees but this trend has vastly
accelerated over the past couple of
years and who could blame them they're
just looking out for themselves and
making the best choices for their
careers but this brings up the question
of where does this leave big Tech as
they slowly lose their status as being
the destination for Superstars what will
happen to their Flagship products like
the metaverse and Google bard also what
will happen to the culture of these
companies as they slowly devolve from
being an engineering playground to being
just another corporate office filled
with politics Antics and egos well
likely nothing all that great so here's
an in-depth look at the big Tech brain
drain and what this means for these
companies and the tech industry at
Large
[Music]
starting off with the biggest question
why in the world are people not
accepting these job offers is the
compensation just not high enough what's
going on well this breaks down into
three major reasons starting off with
the big Tech offers not being all that
hard to come by that's probably an
extremely controversial statement
because for you or me scoring a big Tech
offer might be borderline impossible
but for the people who actually end up
getting these offers it's often not all
that crazy in fact it's not uncommon for
them to apply to 5 to 10 companies and
to get job offers from all of them if
not most of them if you're wondering who
these people are I would recommend
checking out teamblind.com over there
they're everywhere literally half the
post on blind or something along the
lines of should I take a 667 offer at
meta wait for an L7 offer at Google or
keep my L7 Amazon job let me know this
is especially true once you already have
your foot in at one of these companies
after that you don't even have to apply
to other fan companies instead
recruiters from these other companies
will basically beg you on a weekly basis
to come interview with them so the
reality is that for a lot of superstars
once they're already in the industry for
5 or 10 years scoring another big Tech
job offer isn't some sort of Holy Grail
in fact they're often over the whole
idea of working at big Tech in general
which brings us into reason number two
the compensation isn't enough with
slowing growth and high interest rates
big tech companies have largely cut
compensation especially stock comp which
is the most lucrative part of these job
offers but that's not what I'm referring
to when I say that the compensation is
not enough rather what I mean is that
higher compensation alone is not enough
to convince Superstars to join the
reality is that they're often already
multi- millionaires because of how
expensive these cities are it's often
the case that they're not able to retire
even with $2 or $3 million in savings
but while they may not be able to retire
they're definitely well off and never
need to worry about money again as such
they don't make their next job move
purely based on who is offering the
biggest salary they'd often much rather
take a lower job offer with a lot more
scope and growth opportunities I mean
just think about it while it might sound
cool from the out side to say that you
work on the YouTube iOS team what does
that actually entail it's not like
you'll be coding out the new shorts feed
or the new recommendation algorithm from
scratch rather you'll probably be
working on fixing bug 2001 regarding
Community post or debugging some issue
with dark mode and that's not Google's
fault that's simply the reality of
joining any project that's as mature as
YouTube now I can already hear a bunch
of you saying that you'd love to fix
some bugs and earn that much
but that's not exactly how the high
Achievers these companies are targeting
think they'd much rather join a smaller
fintech company or an AI company where
they can actually play a larger role in
product development even if the
compensation is slightly less and that
brings me into the third reason that
Superstars are no longer interested in
big Tech with this compensation
potential sure compensation at smaller
companies may be lower because the cash
portion is lower but they have far
greater growth potential for example
would you rather th get $100,000 worth
of Google stock and work on Google bard
or $100,000 worth of open AI stock and
work on chat GPT from that perspective
the answer is obvious so whether you're
in it for the money or the role itself
big Tech offers simply aren't all that
appealing especially when they're not
that hard to come by but if Superstars
are no longer joining big Tech who
[Music]
is
ironically the question of who is
getting into big Tech today is extremely
easy to answer and breaks down into
three categories starting with the
sellouts the people who always have
their eye on the ball for increasing
status job title and compensation and I
want to note that I'm not criticizing
these people by any means they're just
looking out for themselves as they
should be moreover these people are
usually more than qualified for these
roles as they're just as smart as the o
G Superstars that's why they were able
to crush the interviews and to get in
but their intentions are far different
they're less interested in using their
skills to build the best products and
are more interested in using their
skills to maximize career progression
and compensation a prime example of such
an employee is Quant Engineers if you're
not familiar with Quant Engineers their
jobs are to use their extensive
knowledge and Applied Mathematics data
models algorithms statistics and
calculus to create software that can
trade the financial markets essentially
Quant Engineers are creating insane
algorithms and software just so that
Financial firms can scam 0.5% on natural
gas features or a few cents on bid ask
spreads obviously super monotonous Soul
draining work but it pays extremely well
after all making half a perc on a
billion doll natural gas position adds
up to $5 million in profit every single
trade and it seems that Fang companies
are heading in the exact same direction
especially as they keep pulling back
from moonshot ideas eventually all
that's left are monotonous maintenance
and refinement jobs which only appeal to
people who are really only in it for the
paycheck but at least these candidates
are highly qualified the same cannot be
set about on next category of
opportunists which are the game players
these people don't necessarily have
strong engineering backgrounds or a
passion for Tech they're often stuck in
a corporate job that pays all right or
even a low paying job but what what they
do have is a massive amount of drive to
change their situation and that's when
they hear about all these people in big
Tech earning massive salaries straight
off of college with very little
experience naturally they decide to make
the switch but their strategy usually
has less to do with learning the skills
required for the job and more about
learning the skills required for the
interviews you know grinding out lead
curb problems creating compelling
stories to tell hiring managers notw
workking with as many people as possible
and just playing the game in general
General to be honest this strategy is
way more effective than just being a
good engineer this is why a lot of great
Engineers are never able to break into
Fang they're just not able to sell
themselves but while this is a
phenomenal strategy to get in the door
the effectiveness of these individuals
once they get in the door is a lot more
questionable I mean how much does
solving Le cord problems really
translate into building highly scalable
Solutions or new Innovative products
likely not all that much
but at least these guys are largely here
by choice which cannot be said about our
last category of opportunists which are
the groomed now I don't want to throw
shade at Asians but this is extremely
common within the Asian Community
basically starting from age five parents
will push them to join a bunch of STEM
related EC's coding camps and take a
bunch of Cs classes this way by the time
the kid is 18 regardless of Interest
they're pretty good at coding from there
they'll usually attend a top public
universe if not an IV league go where
they major in CS before they crack their
way into Fang putting the whole ethics
of all of these aside this doesn't
exactly lead to the healthiest Workforce
you basically end up with hundreds of
thousands if not millions of sellouts
game players and groomed individuals
which brings us into the question of
what happens
[Music]
next how exactly each of these groups
got here is vastly different but they
tend to end up having very similar
individualistic motivations job security
maximum pay and promotions which again
are not bad goals to have they're just
not all that great for the company this
sort of environment is what leads to
entrenched workforces with nothing but
office politics much of these employees
efforts don't go into creating the best
products or efficiencies possible rather
they go into outperforming their
teammates and pandering to their bosses
even if that doesn't lead to the best
results for the company the reality is
that most of these guys don't give a
hoot and Hell about the company other
than the status that it gives them and
their growing stock price in fact many
of them don't know how their role is
even linked with the end user most
people would hate this work environment
but these guys thrive in this
environment many of them have been
dealing with such environments for their
entire careers and by the time they're
in their 40s and 50s they're masters of
managing politics and getting exam
exactly what they want this is how you
end up with tech leaders who have no
formal Tech background often times
they're from the marketing department or
the finance department and their
playbook as CEO is usually just
infinitely cutting costs and increasing
efficiencies but this can only take
these companies so far as they Veer
further and further away from what
initially made them successful and soon
enough you end up with your next
generation of intels cisos and ibms
meanwhile the super stars who made Fang
into what it was move on to up and
cominging companies with new promising
Tech and they helped scale these
companies to new leagues far beyond what
the previous generation was able to
achieve and the psycho repeats all over
again not only is Fang experiencing a
brain drain but they're also reaching
Market saturation for the first time
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Harry I'll see you guys
on the next
[Music]
one